hey you guys it's Friday again and it's
time for another movie retrospective
going back to Italy this time around we
actually did another Lucio Fulci movie
couple months ago we did the Beyond
which is probably one of his best-known
ones but today I want to discuss the
first and the so-called gates of Hell
trilogy the movie known as city of the
Living Dead yeah strange movie it is a
little I liked it though it's mostly
imagery but we can get into that well
yeah now the thing about this is that
you know as I said this movie when it
came out on VHS in the United States it
was actually first called the gates of
hell it has subsequently been released
with its you know something closer to
its italian title which is city of the
Living Dead and that's usually what it's
known by now like when it came out on
DVD and stuff this movie actually came
out in 1980 and as I said it's
considered the first movie of full
cheese gates of Hell trilogy
the second of which was the Beyond and
the third of which was the house by the
cemetery which will probably get around
to doing one of these days because
shudder has that as well shudder
actually has all three of them up at the
moment so this one is not I feel like
it's not quite as accomplished as the
beyond and I know this is gonna be very
funny to those of you that are full G
fans but it doesn't have the narrative
coherence and I'm sure I'm probably the
only person that's ever said that I'm
glad I was kind of swimming in certain
areas you know but I still enjoyed the
movie it it looks really good and a
bunch of yeah [ __ ] happens in it but I
spent a lot of the times not not knowing
what the hell was going on well until I
told you to just not worry about it and
that be I said basically this movie it's
not so much like you know how a lot of
sort of just classic just regular movies
I guess quote-unquote have a sort of you
know three acts plot structure structure
yeah you know you got your rising action
you got your climax you got your daenam
ah yeah um this is more like well let's
think of an idea like a rough idea for a
movie and in this case you know the
gates of Hell opening in this particular
town and then we're just going to show
you those that suggest that yeah and
then
we're gonna end the movie so that's
enough that's a fancy way of saying
normally you have a story this one in
this one something happens and you
witness things that people in the town
witness yeah make of it what you will
yeah it's really kind of what what what
it's like now I was watching it I was
enjoying it
I was drinking you know yeah like I do
and I thought I was maybe losing my mind
or getting slightly high and not knowing
that I'd missed something you know like
are these important and you know there
are other people in town so this is the
first time we're seeing them right
because to me Eliza will look alike you
know after after certain amount of
drinks you know you're certain about it
drinks people account I'll buy it I was
like who are these people
you know oh no they just they're just
introducing them now they're just some
people in the town that has seen
specific oh okay so I felt better I felt
like I wasn't losing my mind yeah cuz he
legit thought that he was like so drunk
that he has completely lost all thread
of reality because he had no see that's
what happens when you drink and watch
Lucio Fulci movies everything tequila
you think this you've lost your grip on
me yeah well it was an experience you
know I just started to roll with it like
watching a music video yeah it is a bit
like that energy video it did have cool
music it actually had a background music
that kind of sounded almost kind of like
the dark wave going on in the back yeah
I actually think a Fabio fritzy did the
score for this if I'm not mistaken
towards you you sound like VNV nation
now as I said we you know we talked a
little bit about this on you know our
review of the Beyond which actually also
kinda doesn't make a lot of sense but
makes more sense than this um now the
gates of Hell trilogy is you know much
like I mentioned on the Dario Argento D
bread review where I was talking about
his quote-unquote animal trilogy of his
giallo movies which are more a thematic
trilogy than it's not like a continuing
story or anything like that it's just
kind of like they have similar elements
so they seem like they should
grouped together and that's kind of the
same thing that happened here he's got
like some of the same actors you know in
all three movies they all kind of have
you know Walking Dead zombie type thing
they have some supernatural ass but they
were very gothic atmosphere and all
three of them I believe and I haven't
seen house by the cemetery in a long
time so please correct me if I'm wrong
but all of them are set in the United
States and they were actually filmed
here yeah it looked like it looked like
New Orleans there it was actually
Savannah Georgia Georgia where it was
and Midway Georgia show smoke in New
York City Oh big old country houses you
know and the high ceilings because
there's no AC of the tin roofs you know
they were they were loud you know I
heard there were people friends of the
family had some of those yeah back in
the back in the 70s and they were on
their last legs back in the seventies a
lot of those houses they're all most
important down now they were loud and
they were hot yeah because just you know
I mean it the the the ceiling went right
up basically to the tin roof yeah
yeah that was up there you know twelve
feet and it would just be bacon in the
Sun yeah you were lucky to have a king
isn't like not like bacon like yeah no
bacon is making you old Southern houses
yeah yeah yeah a trip they were they
were creepy they were loud yeah there's
no way you could sneak through a house
like that yeah yeah we already though
they were pretty well and that's I think
that contributes a lot to I mean like I
said what you know where they filmed
some of the cemeteries and stuff like
that that was actually um the main
cemetery with a fellow I think it was in
Manhattan but most of the exteriors of
the houses and stuff when they're
walking around the neighborhoods that's
actually parts of Georgia yeah so all
the interiors were actually shot in Rome
like in a studio as they usually did at
the time and you know again just like in
the beyond it's kind of like a
multinational cast and then later they
kind of dub everyone into English using
sometimes using their voices like
Katriona McCall she's a British actress
so she dubbed her own voice call her
Katriona yeah well she goes by Katherine
McCall too but I think when she was in
Lucio Fulci movies they built her as
Katriona nickname maybe I'm not really
Catherine yeah I like her though she's
in all three of these movies playing
different characters now in this one
this actually has a little bit and I
guess the beyond has this too but it has
a little bit of a Lovecraft
yeah influence you can see the
inspiration yeah in the sense that the
thing that opens the gates of hell is
this priest that hangs himself in a
cemetery yeah in a town called Dunwich
we're done it if you want to be pretty
pedantic about it which they never say
is in Massachusetts but they do say that
it was built over the ruins of the
original Salem which I'm kind of like
well is the original Salem in a
different place than yeah this is actual
Salem because that's still their
original in the south in Georgia
well yeah but sees it like I said they
never mentioned this in Massachusetts
but you know they say Salem so I guess
you're supposed to assume that is
Massachusetts even though you can
clearly tell probably you know they made
these movies mostly for the European
market and the Europeans of those times
would know the south north well there's
probably like whatever it's just like
you know yeah Americans they all eat
hamburgers yeah although we had ramen
today but yeah so so that is what kind
of triggers it off we don't know why the
priest whose name is father Thomas why
his particular suicide opened the gates
of Hell but was it just because it was a
suicide was he evil did he do it on
purpose who knows you just don't worry
about it because you're not gonna find
out so I'm telling you that right now
but it's just kind of the thing that
gets into it and we're just trying to
get the movie done right there using
tropes that came from other things and
right thus to get that this movie had
done and I should say too that Lucio
Fulci just like he did in a lot of his
movies he actually does make a small
cameo in this like as a pathologist and
it's very funny like hearing him dubbed
by an American actor because I'm like I
don't even think he could speak any
English at all I don't know I don't know
if he even a
learn to speak English but yeah so this
this town called Dunwich and this priest
hangs himself in those gates of Hell now
in New York for whatever reason
Catriona McCall she plays a psychic
named Mary Woodhouse and for whatever
reason they're having this seance at
this house in New York City and she sees
the priest hanging himself and figures
out or knows somehow psychically that
this is gonna cause like the gates of
Hell to open which is a bad thing I mean
because it's gonna mean that people are
gonna be coming up out of the graves and
walking around and doing all kind of
crazy [ __ ]
so she says that she screams she drops
dead or so you think
cuz you're thinking Catriona McCall
she's dead like five seconds into the
movie and you're like that can't be
right she's like top-billed right so
you're like she can't be dead already so
they bury her these two like half-assed
grave diggers are like Oh time to go
home let's just kind of leave it
half-buried or whatever this guy who is
like a investigative journalist his name
is Peter and he's played by Christopher
George and he is actually at the
cemetery because he got interested in
this like weird deathless word psychic
death and she said and he happens to be
in the cemetery and hears her because
she wakes up in there she's like oh yeah
she wasn't dead she was alive yes we're
really good buried alive scene which and
I was terrified of that when I was a kid
and every element of what I was afraid
of of being buried alive is covered in
that scene yeah which makes me think
maybe I had seen this and you might you
may have and just remembered that scene
he's trying to get her out with a
pickaxe and that pick axe is going
through the top of the of the coffin and
almost hitting her in the face you know
seems like he's able to break a hole in
it right where her face is and you just
see her face in her mouth screaming from
a hole in the ground it was it's pretty
you know something that you know as a
kid and terrify you
yes digging in a mouth comes up out of
the ground yeah yeah it's like that's
the thing it's yeah it doesn't make a
lot of sense in your thinking like even
when you're watching the movie you're
like guy it's like can you like put the
acts like kind of over to the sides yeah
like just get it right he's already
busted a hole when it slowed down yes I
did get air it's like you know she's got
oxygen yeah but uh you know but like I
said that just the visual image of it is
so cool
like you know her in the coffin and it's
all dark and blue and like this blade
like coming down next to release and
she's like freaking out stuff there's a
lot of good that you you see this movie
you know and they're enjoyable to watch
especially when like I said when you're
not really taking it seriously you just
watch it like this a damn music video
yeah it's just like a series of cool
images and kick-ass Gore yeah put your
brain in neutral when you're watching it
yes have fun and when you see it that
way you can see how these Italian movies
did a lot for the for the newer
generation of horror movies that started
coming out of the United States later in
the 80s yeah like you can see where like
Evil Dead 1 yes you got a lot of their
tone and stuff like you know Brie
animator
you say you can see even I would say
maybe even Friday the 13th series yeah
borrowed from these movies like this did
for the American horror genre what
Sergio Leone's spaghetti westerns did
for you know good modern westerns like
that you know yeah forgiven and Josey
Wales and High Plains Drifter you know
the Italians were good with tone and
stylistic element right they weren't
real good with story structure all the
time yeah they didn't care about that
they just wanted to show you some cool
[ __ ] and yeah they'd have an emotional
reaction like going through it basically
was like going through a haunted house
yeah that's a good way of putting it
haunted houses don't have plots really
you just go through like having a
nightmare
yeah yeah it's just kind of like they
wanted to show you just really
disturbing images with enough of a story
you know kind of threading it together
that you know it at least had a little
bit of coherence like you can kind of
just follow along with it right like I
said the basic outline yeah it's a very
basic story like
yeah the gates of Hell open and then you
just see all these scenes of mayhem and
like oh yeah people over here see it and
then some people over here see it and
then some people over here see it and
you get to see what everybody sees and
that's over and then they kind of meet
up later on like they're all kind of
interconnected like cuz you know there
is one [ __ ] grand finale yeah there is
one point where were married the psychic
you know after she gets dug out and she
says you know I know I don't know where
the town is but it's the city of the
Living Dead this guy hung himself and
his name is father Thomas she's like I
saw the his tombstone in my vision so we
have to figure out where this town is we
can get there because she somehow knows
like again psychically that they have to
like you know open up the tomb or do
something about him and like close it
before all the dead people start walking
around so they so that's like there's a
there's a parallel story of you know her
in the newspaper guy trying to find
Dunwich and then you go back to the town
of Dunwich and you see like all the
crazy [ __ ] that like starts to happen um
you know this priest like I said he's
like a dead person but he like kind of
can pop in and out like a ghost you know
what I mean so they're they're not like
traditional like chamblee kind of
zombies yes they're like all yucky and
they have like worms and rot and
everything like that like all over the
faces and they're really disgusting
looking but they can kind of like buy
located and [ __ ] so they're like super
adorable right you know they're like
manifestations I guess you could say
yeah kind of like yeah kind of like from
the fog yeah you know from the movie the
fog they're like revenue they're a
revenant morons they can be solid for a
minute and then they vanished and then
it come somewhere else yeah now the
thing that a lot of people really like
about this movie is that and you have to
consider this came out in 1980 and like
I said the Italians particularly in the
70s and 80s they were way ahead on the
gore meter yeah so a lot of their movies
were cut in various other countries or
banned you know even for the US market
some of them were cut up and everything
but they had like a reputation among
horror fans you know in the 70s and 80s
it's like oh you got to see this
[ __ ] [ __ ] cuz like American movies
just weren't doing that level of gore at
this stage I mean you know if you see
[ __ ] Cannibal Holocaust and you see
this it's like it's still pretty
disgusting like even by today's
standards yeah because you know there's
some great scenes in this where very
famously the one weirdo character Bob
who has a self inflating sex doll with a
front loaded [ __ ] know which is very is
I love that scene so much because it's
just like he's in his like abandoned
Shack or whatever whatever where he
lives and he takes out his little sex
doll and she's all like deflating some
one of his old sex dolls and he throws
it and it goes and like you know what I
mean it gets big when you need it to
just like but it's like that it's like
yeah and it didn't it didn't really
explain itself and just to show you [ __ ]
that's it it didn't need to be that way
like he could have like you know
inflated it or I could have already been
inflated but it's like they just did
that cuz I guess they thought it was fun
the Italian scene was its own you know
it didn't cost them much to go to the
theater people didn't really have you
know I don't think televisions were
super common in Italy in 1988 they
imagine everybody did but evidently
people went to the theater you know like
once a day yeah they are the very oh
they made a lot of movies very likely
going to the movies and like a big
social yeah it was like a scene where
they come out with one movie they liked
it so they said well we gotta top that
and then somebody else has come so the
movies would get progressively more
redonkulous yeah because they trying to
step on each other's dicks and stuff and
the Americans crowd would have no idea
what the [ __ ] going on they they've
just seen these things in a vacuum yeah
you know so they looked quite bizarre to
us yeah they still do there's something
kind of Japanese about them the way that
they're filmed they sometimes feel like
a Japanese movie the structure of them
is more Asian than American yeah because
if you've ever Slyke a lot of people
that like j-horror like you know the
Asian horror films a lot of them are
more like have a more episodic quality
like if you see something like for
example you know just pulling out of my
ass like The Grudge it isn't like you
know like I said
ABC it's kind of like a and then a
repeats right you're seeing the same
thing happen over and over again like
it's more cyclical I guess that's the
same thing with most anime most animate
doesn't mean yes really yeah it's just
amazing yeah they tell stories in a
different way that's usually like I said
The Grudge it's kind of like tells the
same haunting like from three different
families successive families that live
in this haunted house so you know it's
not like a linear type narrative at
least not from our perspective and I
feel like this is kind of the same thing
where like I said they have a situation
and they're just showing you like
snapshots you know they're like there's
a bunch of guys in a bar and all of a
sudden the mirror breaks and then the
wall cracks open you know I mean it's
like supernatural [ __ ] in the town yeah
you know and you get to see like I said
the guy the creepy guy Bob who is
initially blamed for all of the weird
shenanigans going on in town before it
gets really supernatural because he's
like apparently it's hinted that he's
like some weird child we were pedophile
yeah like a pedophile
yeah so he's kind of blamed for it and
later on his he's he's friends with this
girl and she's like trying to like
comfort him or something cuz he's like
oh weird shits going on and he saw about
the priest ghost and everything like
that and her dad comes in there thinking
that he's like molesting the girl and he
basically takes Bob's head and just very
slowly pushes it on the drill lathe and
did against drill bit all the way I've
ever seen I remember that [ __ ] really
good effect looks like it looks like it
goes right to his head yeah it's I mean
I'm not really sure like I'm with the
I'm sure nothing budget they had to pull
this off yeah that looks really real
yeah I could tell they had a bunch of
spent special effects gags that they
could yeah and they said this is what
this is what we can do right now
we haven't worked these gags into this
movie that's basically how they did and
I think that what I saw right that's
full cheese thing he's like and Dario
Argento does that a bit too where he's
like we want these particular violent
set pieces and then we're just gonna
kind of put this yeah so the drill scene
that's probably the most famous but uh
equally famous I think is the one scene
where there's a guy and a girl that
don't really figure into the plot
they're just townsfolk or whatever and
they're making out in a car yeah and
that you know it's dark and foggy and
all this kind of [ __ ] and then they look
out they see the a goat that goes to the
priest like hang in there and then all
of a sudden like her eyeballs start
bleeding yeah which I guess is like a
stigmata type thing I don't know there's
like a catholicism vomited up or she
vomits up all of her internal organs
were and some of that like you could
tell like in the close-ups it was a fake
head but actually in the longshots they
actually made this poor actress eat a
whole bunch of tripe with the red [ __ ]
on it and then throw it back so she is
actually throwing up intestines they're
just not hers yeah they're sheep
intestines so I think about anything
else about this one we've been going on
about but no sir Oh also you get to see
like a rain of maggots yeah all this
other stuff
now one thing I want to mention which I
think that was actually an inspiration
for a Skinny Puppy song God God's gift
maggots yeah I think there was a scene
like that in Suspiria to that where
maggots were although it wasn't
supernatural they were just like maggots
all up in the ceiling and then it
started coming down through the ceiling
but yeah there was also so I just wanted
to talk a little bit about the ending
because a lot of people are really super
confused by the ending of this because
apparently here's the thing like they
get to Dunwich they get down in the tomb
which is actually a really cool scene
like you know like under the ground and
like there's all these [ __ ] skeletons
and [ __ ] under there um they end up like
sticking a big wooden cross like through
the preet like right into his crotch and
it's all rotten and gross and everything
and then so they saved the day they
saved the world they come crawling out
of the tomb and it's daytime and then
they're crawling out gone oh yeah oh we
did everything and then there's like
this little kid that's in the movie
called John John his whole family got
killed it's you know it's a long story
and he's there with the cops
and then they're looking at the kid like
oh he survived yay and then the kid
starts running toward them and then
catch her and I McCall and the other guy
who lived her like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] and then she starts screaming
and then freeze frame on the kid running
toward them and then the screen just
cracks and that's the end and some
people are like what is that all about
like what what does that mean that mean
anything you just ended the move no yeah
okay now the story goes okay
that when they were making the movie
when they were in the editing process
the editor spilled coffee on the final
scenes of the movie and they didn't have
the time or the money to do anything
about it I've so I've heard that story
I've also heard that the kid at the end
was actually supposed to be a zombie and
the cops were suppose to be zombies and
they were supposed to have like worms
that [ __ ] all over his face but the kid
didn't want to do it right so I've heard
that story too so I'm not sure if they
actually did film some scenes with the
kid like and the kid running at them and
the kids zombie and the cops are zombies
which actually would have made sense as
an ending cuz they came out thinking
they saved the world and they're like oh
[ __ ] and everybody's zombies you know
what I mean so that would have made
sense but the fact that they didn't do
that I don't know if the ending got
destroyed and that was all the footage
they had left or if the kid just was
like no worms you know I'm not doing it
so they just said well we're just gonna
go with this and we're gonna crack it at
the end so maybe people pick up on the
fact that he's supposed to be dead or
he's supposed to be a zombie or
something like that but that's what I
heard now came off of me yeah I was
always confused and a lot of people are
confused by that ending but those are
the stories that I've heard about it
which would explain a lot right because
had the kid looked like a zombie then
that would have made sense right as an
ending all right so let's wrap up this
discussion of the Lucio Fulci film city
the Living Dead like I said you know
we've done the beyond are already we did
a couple months ago we'll probably end
up doing the house by the cemetery a
couple months down the line just so I
can say I completed the trilogy and like
I said all three of them are on shudder
at the moment if you want to check them
out and also I've heard that arrow the
UK releasing company has done like a
really nice blu-ray of it with like a
lot of special features and like cold
booklets and all kind of [ __ ] in there
so check that out if you're a full chief
fan and remember if you liked the show
like share subscribe and all your social
media if you'd like to financially
support the show you can go to our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
where
press calm and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation
remember the movie retrospectives just
like this one come out every Friday we
also have 13 o'clock matinee two three
new movies in the theater that comes out
every Sunday and our regular episodes
are up every Tuesday so check them out
we will see you next time